The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: So we have a class
Car here, object as usual.
The init method here takes in
self as usual, a w, and a d.
So Car gets initialized
with two parameters.
And we assign the wheels data
attribute to the first one
and the doors data
attribute to the second one.
And then we're
going to also assign
the color data attribute
to be the empty string.
So I'm giving you
four choices here.
And the question says,
which of the above
is a getter method for
the number of wheels?
So getter method
is something that's
going to get a data attribute.
A method is really
just a function.
So of course, we're
going to have def.
get_wheels is a
good name for it.
Since it's a method
for this class,
we have to have self
in the parameters.
So we know it's going
to be between C and D.
And so then what are
we going to return?
The first one's going
to return wheels, which,
in this particular
case, is just going
to be a variable that we haven't
defined, but it's a variable.
A getter returns
a data attribute
of a particular instance.
So we actually have
to say self dot
if we want to return a data
attribute of an instance,
as opposed to just
a regular variable.
So the correct answer
is D. Great job.